I'm Magnum and the funniest thing is
sometimes like they'll fill it like
necessary to announce my presence
yeah this is very strange
it's very strange but that's cool though
that that means that it's hitting some
sort of [ __ ] and to choose a Hispanic
it's weird because it makes it so
relevant right gab right we have
somebody from you know Filipino so we're
like kindred spirit yeah yeah to have a
Higgins as somebody from middle-earth is
an interesting take mythological you
know cool man and hope you're trying to
weed out jinn is that what it is well we
already pitched how you die oh my gosh
can I see we have a spoiler or less what
seemed that what you and I are filming
on Monday yeah what are you gonna be you
actually going to be fully naked are you
gonna commit well it's so funny because
I talked to I was like it but it's like
don't talk about the scene I get a call
from Jean
two weeks ago and he goes ask them to
talk to you about do you mind being
naked on the show and I go I don't like
to do things 50/50 I'm not gonna wear
that tan spandex thing I don't want it a
merkin I go I want to be fully oxide
[ __ ] naked he wants to be free I know
but what's funny is they didn't call me
and me like do you mind if
you will be it's not gonna mind it's a
magical thing to see me naked
boaty yeah and they said it would
legally we can't so you can't I can't go
full nude on it they said there's a
who's that showrunner what's his name
Peter Peter no good because Dean called
me in the show room too and I could hear
him say he can't do it legally as in
isn't you can't show your genitive yeah
I can't show my dick okay of course no
it's CBS yeah but I do the scene
completely naked but then blur it you
know Chris Pratt did that on Parks and
Rec didn't tell anyone he took his dick
out to get Amy Poehler to laugh yeah and
he got a big note for NBC and they were
like you can't be doing that on set yeah
I know it's so cuz I just did a Netflix
show no see small either regular size
average size sack in order for you to
pull your junk into yeah and then I'll
feel comfortable and and considerable
heft put it in the sock yeah it's just
you and I in the scene
[Laughter]
[Music]